for the first time ever college athletes
are able to use their status to strike
endorsement deals sponsorships and even
charge for appearance fees and
commercials like this one college
athletes can be in commercials now dr
pepper is the one dj deserves last july
a new ncaa policy allowed college
athletes to start earning money on
endorsements after pressure from state
lawmakers and a related supreme court
ruling that warned the ncaa that broadly
limiting athlete compensation would
violate anti-trust laws there's this
batch of 500 000 student athletes every
year that can now
monetize their name image and likeness
and so i think overall you do have a
market that will grow into a
multi-billion dollar market open doors
says brands are on track to pay over 579
million dollars to student athletes in
the first 12 months since the supreme
court ruling i've been able to do
some really cool things in the past few
months since the rule change i've gotten
to work with some amazing brands the
also greek yogurt bars are one of my
favorite mindful indulgences
so how exactly are these new rules
playing out in this new era for college
sports and what are student athletes
doing to cash in
college athletes have long been
classified as amateurs by the ncaa even
as they helped generate billions for
their colleges and universities the rule
change allowing college athletes to
profit off of their name image and
likeness or nil came after years of
mounting legal and political pressure
there was a handful of states led by
california that push forward legislation
at the state level that would allow
college athletes to sign endorsement
deals and in order to get ahead of
college athletes
in one state being able to profit off
their name image and likeness and not
others the ncaa changed its rules so far
28 states have adopted legislation that
gives student athletes more control over
their nil
it basically says that if your state has
a law that lets you profit from your
name imagine like this go ahead if your
state doesn't you know you can still go
ahead and do it but under the
limitations that the ncaa is going to
set the new policy impacts more than 480
000 athletes across the ncaa's three
divisions open doors a sports technology
company that helps navigate athletes
through this new landscape says that
some of the highest profile athletes
have made over one hundred thousand
dollars in the first six months since
the new rules took effect for instance
paige beckers a basketball star at the
university of connecticut became the
first college player to sign an
endorsement deal with gatorade
i won national gatorade player of the
year in high school and that's when our
relationship kind of started the
financial details of the deal weren't
disclosed but gatorade said it is a
multi-year partnership jim cavall is the
ceo of influencer a mobile app that is
helping over 100 000 athletes build
their brand on social media and navigate
the new nil landscape part of gaming is
you got to do social media and your
brand like an influencer does
most athletes think it's just about
playing well in the court but it's both
when you do both that's when you can
explode this thing influencer says the
average deal size for student athletes
on its platform is around eleven hundred
dollars
you see
a handful of athletes actually make six
and seven figures pretty fast but then
you see
thousands of athletes do 20 t-shirt
deals with barstool and so it's a really
wide spectrum according to open doors
national brands account for 57.75
of student athlete nil compensation
while local brands make up the rest so
you have you know maybe a national food
chain like zaxby's or chick-fil-a but
then it's the local franchises that are
partnering with players on a certain
team or lots of car dealerships
hello i'm oz brennan i'm lsu's
quarterback
not all brand deals result in monetary
payouts athletes can partner with a
sports brand in exchange for free gear
or get sponsored by a restaurant for
free meals and there are you know other
athletes that have been able to have
smaller deals as well where it's maybe
you know the arkansas offensive lineman
they get a gift card to a restaurant and
they post about it and they rave about
the meal online a major asset many
student athletes bring to the table is
their social media following
particularly on instagram
factors like posting frequently and
having a high engagement rate can drive
up an athlete's value all those things
determine
a a evaluation that could be anywhere
from 50 cents per follower to more than
a dollar per follower trinity thomas a
gymnast at the university of florida has
over 54 000 followers on instagram by
posting more than once or twice per
month she could potentially see a forty
thousand dollar windfall um i think the
most exciting part is like kinda not
feeling like gated in like you can kind
of just
do what you love and try new things and
kind of put yourself out there another
way college athletes profit from their
skills is by giving lessons while they
weren't banned from doing this before
they couldn't mention their status as a
collegiate athlete in promoting their
services and so with the new nil
opportunities i hope to be able to like
kind of organize a clinic and
also do some camps maybe even one of my
own so many student athletes have
sizable social media followings but
aren't headed for professional careers
this is the case for leah clapper
another gymnast at the university of
florida who is trying to maximize her
time as a student athlete before
graduating in 2023 a big huge venture
that i started was a gymnastics board
game company and that would not have
been possible before nil so i teamed up
with one of my former coaches and we
created a gymnastics board game and we
got to
use my status as a florida gator to help
market it and use my connections in my
social media platform as well which was
a huge help the rapidly evolving
landscape of nil rules carries
significant implications for the future
of collegiate athletic recruitment
there's broad fear that this is going to
lead to a pay-for-play model where the
richest schools get the best athletes
and that there's going to be lots of bad
recruiting inducements and this is
something that the ncaa has been
battling in college sports for pretty
much as long as it's existed loose
guidelines set by the ncaa have left a
lot up to interpretation as colleges
navigate various compliance challenges
the one broad
thing that all these rules say is that
the schools can't actively
pay
a player but there's nothing saying that
oh a coach can't have a conversation
with boosters when he's out of lunch
with donors and say yeah it'd be really
great if we got some great nil deals
lined up for my athletes and it's
unclear if that's against the rules
right now it's uncertain when or if the
federal government will step in to
regulate nil rules but for now student
athletes are taking advantage of a new
profitable era in college sports
athletes can get a head start on
financial independence i honestly think
that it's changed the course of my
career